ah yes
oh this thing was an interview he's a 10
but his dad is Andrew Tate
negative zero you can make negative zero
I don't know
random guy walks up hey how you doing
how you doing I'm doing great Las Vegas
[ __ ] sucks okay dude so first of all
Billy Bob Thornton second of all
absolutely no as soon as he walks up
that this is gonna take a [ __ ] sour
turn
so here we go absolutely okay a Las
Vegas [ __ ] sucks what do you want to
know about it I mean the way the girl
laughs
I'm good on that a lot of people want to
[ __ ] take people around here okay
what do you want to know about it I'm
good I'm good on that are you I am why
are you filming her
why am I I asked her to film her where
did you I did you're okay with that yeah
because these are [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
go ahead
go ahead all right it's all up to you we
already did it
we already did it dude what a Time suck
this guy is you know like dude you're
just holding up what's going to be
happening hey how's it just holding it
yes I am Las Vegas [ __ ] sucks
people take people huh
you're on camera now too I'm
fantastically on camera
absolutely a foreign dude
I am fantastically on camera
yeah you [ __ ] don't even know not a
brag dude not a flex I play with bands
you don't even know because they're not
successful um I hate people that take
[ __ ] people are you that person no
I'm not why would you think because I
want to kill them because they are all
[ __ ] here in Las Vegas okay I'm not
from Las Vegas neither am I I travel the
world I'm a musician yeah I hate to see
people yeah okay thank you
I mean and then she leaves just go do
your thing the guy like
was trying to already
the way he answers
but his dad is Andrew Tate the question
you know negative zero the you can make
negative zero this whole thing is so
insane
she has a shirt on that says [ __ ]
and he's got a hat on the crazy guy's
hat on that says fcuk
the guy walks up hey how you doing how
you doing I'm doing great Las Vegas
[ __ ] sucks
foreign
I'm doing great Las Vegas [ __ ] sucks
how much is that guy's wife been looking
him for him for 30 years
I know about it
I mean does it you're not included guy
I'm good on that a lot of people want to
[ __ ] take people around here dude
this guy is like honestly I I'll tell
you right now I know a guy like this
that isn't like this yet that's going to
be like this in 20 years what do you
want to know about it I'm good I'm good
on that are you I am why are you filming
her
dude this guy thinks he's being such a
bad he thinks he's Liam Mason and taken
and he's wearing a [ __ ] birds of
California shirt and a and maroon
stained shorts
with a bag of what I wonder what the
[ __ ] is in there is absolutely insane
and his leg is bleeding wow his leg is
bleeding dude
why am I I asked her to film her where
did you I did I mean wow God it's just
so much sadness out there mental health
um
to sad
but you know what it's like people say
you gotta give people a pass when they
have mental health but then also if you
really think about it definitely Nazis
were suffering from mental health and
look what they uh [ __ ] accomplished
so
you know maybe also take it seriously
even if they're saying [ __ ]
um
[Music]
[Music]